Mr Wilson 86 you're the sole reason for
this video existing let's take a look at
this first early Gameplay trailer for
unrecorded The Body cam FPS wishlist on
Steam now let's take a look at this
trailer because I have heard some things
about this game but I don't think we've
seen such a big long trailer crazy 18
million views in like what this was
posted today
this is just insane does it have any
audio it does
so this is a body cam FPS like look at
this I mean let's just freeze this for a
bit like even I mean Twitter Twitter
traditionally had like the worst
compression and but I think if you have
like Twitter blue or something I mean
his verified so he's probably got like
Twitter blue or something point being I
think Twitter has good quality videos
now which is really the the real kind of
mind blow I think in this video but
anyway like just like take a look at
this
like I'm gonna try my best here to also
look at this from a technical point of
view but like this is a game like I'm
just I'm immediately Blown Away speaking
of being blown away look at the sky
being blown out here like you see how we
can barely see like this thing like this
kind of power pole or whatever it is
like you can barely see those pixels
like let's really zoom in here like look
at that the fact that it's kind of like
it's just completely blown out because
remember this is supposed to be a body
cam FPS so a body cam like a GoPro or
something it's not gonna be like a
cinematic camera it's probably not even
going to be as good quality as your
phone of course it depends it's not like
impossible to make a good quality body
cam but the point is you can kind of
tell that like I mean the image quality
isn't fantastic again could be Twitter
but the point is that's a really
important detail these kind of
highlights I talked about this in the
other kind of unreal realistic Unreal
Engine reaction video I did I'll have it
linked up there that was like around a
year ago I think uh it was also kind of
you know not not doing the unfair kind
of HDR things that games can do where
they can just be like nah this guy's
blue because there's nothing stopping
you from being like let's tone down
those pixels let's up these pixels it's
like you have infinite dynamic range but
here we're seeing you know sometimes the
lack of quality is almost quality in the
department of photorealism which is
really interesting well like on frame
one and I'm already talking a lot but
but I'll have this linked obviously in
the description below if you want to
watch it yourself first before you hear
my commentary on it but you can also
just see how much like when it's shaking
a little bit like it goes look at that
the quality drops it's almost like you
know the motion blur that's happening
here even though it's seemingly subtle
is really kind of replicating a fairly
low shutter speed of an actual camera
filming this and of course the
animations like the animations have to
be really good like look I've paused
this this looks like garbage but that's
good that's what makes it look good you
know I remember back in the day people
used to like make crazy stupid VFX
videos that they would they would try
and make it seem real like I don't know
know some meteor crashing into the Earth
that doesn't seem very real like a car
crash or something and they'd upload it
like to Facebook or to Instagram or
whatever and lots of people would be
like this is crazy like a lot of people
would believe it a lot of people would
think it was real but no it's just CGI
it's just visual effects and one of the
things that they did to make it look so
good and to make it so believable is
they didn't they didn't film it on a
cinema camera they filmed it on like I
don't know a phone of that time like
this is like 2010 or something so I'm
not talking about like the phones of
today but like back then they'd film it
on like a little phone or something it'd
be like SD like 640 by 480 or something
or 640 by I don't know 360. and they'd
obviously match the the CGI the visual
effects like compositing to actually be
that kind of low res and bad quality and
it just looks so much more realistic my
point being it's easier to take kind of
really really bad looking footage and
put some CGI in that and pass that off
as believable compared to if you have
like this full HD like 4K video that's
just really clean captured by like a
professional camera and I'm not trying
to compare this to that because
obviously when the camera does stop it's
not like the lowest quality 360p video
you've ever seen like as in the image
quality but nonetheless this obviously
doesn't look like it's captured by a
cinema camera which I think is also
important now the exposure just dimmed
so much as well I think he's very
aggressive with the exposure slider here
we've all been there well actually maybe
I'm just old but we've all been there
back in the day when you'd have like a
little you know film camera and it would
have like auto focus Auto exposure and
then you put like a subject in front of
like a bright window and then the whole
photo is just black because there was
like so much brightness that the camera
is like I better dial down the exposure
and it's ruined your photo I'm getting
those kind of vibes from here which is I
guess realistic
all right let's shut up and watch this a
bit the ground like
these things on the ground
are a little bit interesting I almost
feel like they're not lit very well
because there's not much light in here
and yet like you can almost like I can't
see many Shadows or ambient occlusion
here for some reason like obviously
there's some here but I don't know
that's if I had to pick something before
you all Hate Me by the way of course
this looks good of course this basically
looks real I'm just I'm trying to
critique it let's keep watching yeah I
don't know the ground just looks a bit
weird but I'm also getting photo scan
Vibes like that's the thing from the
ground right this almost looks like a
photo scan you know a photo scan like
when you try and like I'm talking about
like photogrammetry like you know you
take all these photos of like something
3D it could be like I don't know a water
bottle on your desk it could be you know
the the floor of this like garage or
wherever we are and you take it from
like every single possible angle and
then you use some like software to kind
of make a 3D model out of that that's
extremely high poly and the textures on
it well the textures are basically the
photos you took which means that of
course it looks real but then and again
the lighting on it might not be quite
right and that's kind of what I'm seeing
here this is really looking kind of like
photogrammetry to me and like as in it's
got that photogrammetry look again I
have no idea how this guy made this no
clue whatsoever I think I've heard of
this game from like last year or
something maybe very briefly but I know
nothing technical about how this came
about I just know it's Unreal Engine 5.
but that I suspect probably doesn't
matter too much maybe nanite though
would be really helping with the high
poly count of photogrammetry and like
Photo scanned assets that's probably
true and then of course Lumen would kind
of be able to maybe light those really
high detailed nanite meshes that's
probably what was that animation
like I did running I don't know that
just did not look real to me
let me put my headphones on it's getting
hectic oh we're going to see some firing
here okay there was a bit of interesting
blurring around the edges here which
shots fired takes me out of it a little
bit I guess he's trying to replicate
some kind of suppression like the thing
is though like looking at all of these
textures like this is what people don't
understand like for those of you who
don't know who I am by the way first of
all hi second of all I'm a game engine
developer I used to work for EA on
frostbite and a mobile engine called
Osiris then I left and now I'm making my
own engine called Hazel Hazel does not
have anywhere near the technology of
Unreal Engine 5 but I could probably
make something that looks 90 as good as
this and in fact part of me really wants
to do that because I think that lots of
people just don't understand the fact
that it is possible and it has been
possible for a long time to make an
environment that does look like this and
so when I'm looking at this it can be
difficult to pull it off in the context
of an actual video game that people want
to play and this kind of body cam
footage Vibe is actually a really cool
aesthetic and a really cool idea but
it's definitely possible and so when I'm
looking at this like these textures to
me again it just looks like someone went
to this Warehouse took photos of
everything
done like slapped it on done if this
suddenly becomes like I don't know a
dynamic lighting situation where it's
like suddenly Dusk and it's golden hour
and this is just all completely
different I'll be way more impressed but
at the moment as cool as it looks as
realistic as it looks you know it's kind
of like this is this might be a
generalization but it's kind of like
taking a photo of something slapping it
onto a texture in like unity and then
being like that's photo realistic
it's a yes it's a photo it is realistic
is that MN so it's kind of like well
what's the difference if you can just
photo scan a bunch of stuff use nanite
to make it a bit you know manageable
with the high poly and you know all the
lotting and kind of stuff that it does
dynamically now basically and then you
you obviously use the original textures
from your photos like Ian Hubert in
Hubert for those of you who don't know
by the way fantastic artist uses blender
to make absolutely crazy photo realistic
environments and he's got this great
series on his Channel right now called
dynamodream he does this a lot like in
his blender workflow he'll take like
photos images of things and project them
in 3D space onto meshes and so I
basically just projected those pictures
back onto some rough 3D geometry and
that was most of the battle right there
I think I took like three different
camera angles and and mapped them out
and you know combine that with a couple
handmade pieces and the result is
incredibly realistic so that's kind of
like the vibe that this is giving me
anyway let's take a look at the action
because now that stuff's actually
happening now the gameplay is happening
it's actually much more of a tell of
like the the talent I guess again not
trying to like I'm not trying to be
negative I'm not trying to disparage
this this is clearly a really good work
of art and looks like an amazing game
that honestly I'm almost surprised we
haven't seen anything like this before
but now that it's more like interactive
and there's a gunfight happening and
stuff's happening the play is engaging
more rather than walking around a static
environment we get to see more so let's
take a look
it's the end of a work week it's Friday
maybe I'm just being salty but like
again I am enjoying this I don't know
why I have to keep uh
trying to prove that
the UI could definitely be done better
for those of you didn't see that was
just yeah like a 5 out of 15 here
be nicer if you could actually you know
you'd have to eject the magazine take a
look at it like actually and be like
yeah all you know on the side and see
how many bulls there are and is there
one in the chamber but you know just
because the graphics are realistic
doesn't mean the gameplay has to be
yeah this just looks like a
photogrammetry set okay so there's a bit
of like there's um puddles here which
reflect stuff but again like you know
what would this be you could just do
this with like this regular reflection
probes like it's you know statically
capture the environment have like
basically a camera here capture the
environment into like a cube map when
you're baking the scene or whatever and
you but you're basically good to go
the face is a blurred which is really
interesting that I guess that that adds
a lot probably to the uh body cam vibe
[Music]
this would be really cool to experience
though
this is a good little test of uh Dynamic
lighting as well because obviously that
Spotlight from the flashlight is like
making Dynamic shadows as you can see
but everything's kind of so fast and
there's so much motion blur which you
would add like you'd probably add quite
a bit of motion blur to simulate again
the fact that well that's a dark
environment you know this tiny sensor of
like a body cam would mean that the
shutter speed would have to be quite low
which would mean you would get more
motion blur in the actual footage
and thus it would look worse which is a
good thing if you're trying to both
create something realistic but then also
kind of make it easier to sell I guess
just looking around yeah and that looks
really good the suppression effects
again are a bit oh it's kind of cool a
drone
foreign
the animations look pretty decent I
guess the Gap like for the gun reloading
and everything
I wonder if there's gonna be blood
effects when you shoot someone
well there's some shooting someone
interesting ragdoll
and he kind of didn't show any blood I
think
oh hang on let's see that reflection
somehow the reflection like
looks much higher quality than the
actual
thing
it's almost like he's he's got a filter
over like but that would just be over
everything wouldn't it so it's strange
maybe it's just a maybe maybe that's not
maybe that's not real it's just it feels
like it is
and like I don't know like that van man
scratch off the windshield a bit
I know this is a very pre-release kind
of video but
still
that looks like the bottom of a CPU
right there
I really am a programmer I know
going downhill
it does look very does look very cool
though
the people don't look that great up
close to be honest though just the way
his clothes are on the sleeve just looks
like a Counter-Strike model
and that's it that's the trailer
I mean I I mean don't get me wrong like
I'll dip I'll probably pick up this game
let's see what other people are saying
I'm gonna get a lot of hate for this but
this level of realism in video games
should be heavily moderated in shooters
for anyone under a certain age or her
parents do their job this little realism
for shooting and killing makes me feel
uncomfortable I agree actually
yeah
that's an interesting consideration how
is this different from watching a war
movie
well I mean in a war movie you're not
the one doing the killing you're just
watching it so I think that's a bit
different here you're like going around
shooting people with the intent to kill
them Unreal Engine 5.1 will be great but
should be moderated heavily
yeah that's that's
really interesting with AI as well being
able to generate federalistic things and
like deep fakes and now game engines
being able to render stuff more or less
realistic
it's far too real like that is a
consideration that is actually really
interesting like it's almost like the
ethics of making games photorealistic
like what is that apart from like a
technical point of view that people have
been striving for forever to make
interactive experiences like this photo
realistic now it's kind of like now that
we're basically almost there in my
opinion we still have a long ways to go
but now that we're basically almost
there let's just say we're looking at it
from a different point of view minimum
requirement minimal requirements space
shuttle price as a dolphin memory yeah
I'd be interested to see what he played
that on
um probably a fairly like good
development rig but yeah there you go JD
Mr Wilson you got your reaction video
hope you guys enjoyed thanks for
watching let me know what your take is
on this in the comments below did you
agree with me did you disagree with me
am I dumb and have a great weekend guys
I'll see you next time goodbye